Welcome To The Sky News Daily I'm Neil
Patterson and look hands up I will admit
that we have gone a bit coronation Daft
here on the podcast desk last episode I
took you the length of the country from
the silly Isles to Scotland gauging
public opinion of Charles and the Royals
more widely in the run-up to the Big D
but there is one interview from my
travels that we didn't play
g'day and you've dressed appropriately
I'm feeling the animal magnetism already
thank you get in here coming
[Laughter]
the author Cassie Lett is an avoid
Republican she's also a decades-long
friend of the Royals I think actually I
need a tiara to go with it don't you and
you can hear more from her on another of
our podcasts Queen Camilla For the Love
of Charles but what you're about to
listen to is the long chat that we had
at Kathy's home in Northwest London
winning her Corgi jumper especially for
the occasion and armed with a dozen
photo albums she gave me real insight
into what Charles and Camilla are like
when the Crowns come off
because I'm a republican I'm from
Australia and I think it's time
Australians stood on our own two thongs
you know and came in from the rain in
the monarchy rain whenever I'm talking
about the royal family which I do
sometimes I like to be a little bit
frivolous because I don't take it all
that seriously even though they are
friends of mine Charles and Camilla and
I I like them very very much you are
friends with the Royals but describe
yourself as a republican square that
Circle for me
well you take people as you find them
and you know Prince Charles princes are
supposed to be charming and he is
charming and also I think he was so
prescient I mean he was way ahead of his
time on all those environmental issues
which I can connect with him on that big
time so you know you you can't help
liking them he's I would say Charles's
charm is more disarming than a U.N
peacekeeping Force really and and also
Camilla she treats everyone the same
from maid to Monarch so she has a strong
egalitarian streak which resonates with
me and if you look at Charles a lot of
his friends from spite Milligan to
Miriam Margulies to Stephen Fry he likes
funny irreverent mischievous people
which I think is a good sign so I've
always seen myself as his kind of female
fall staff but whether that remains now
that he's been elevated to to King I
don't know we shall see it was Camilla
that you became friends well yes I met
Camilla in the 90s because she was very
good friends with John Mortimer who
wrote the Rumple series and at time she
was Public Enemy Number One I mean
there's stories about women throwing
bread rolls at her in the supermarket
and that sort of stuff because she was
seen as the other woman and the one who
destroyed Diana which is such a
simplistic view of any marriage she
endeared herself to me immediately
because she told me that
so many American women kept sending her
surreptitiously their cosmetic surgeons
cards because they couldn't believe that
she would go around looking so wrinkly
and crinkly and of course that just gave
her more laughter lives if you read
between those lines what you'll see is a
woman of wit and warmth empathy
intelligence she was Public Enemy Number
One she suffered all that emotional and
mental abuse for so long from the
general public and from the media
perhaps that's why she is so empathetic
with the underdog she's a great
campaigner for women's rights and on
literacy and things like that which
chimes with me as well because they're
the they're the issues that I care about
so yes it is an interesting conundrum
about how how I can like them so much
and have such um respect and admiration
for them but at the same time not really
believe in what they stand for not in
Australia anyway but you you met her
presumably what was it was a very very
difficult time for her I mean how did
the way that she was treated not just by
the Press but by the public I mean how
did that have an effect on her I think
I think rent because you know I always
say that women are each other's human
Wonder bras uplifting supportive and
making each other look bigger and better
there's an image I'm not going to be
able to shift
and she has a lot of female friends in
fact when I said to her how are you
surviving
the myopic
so ferocious and brutal and she said my
women friend and she said I'm just going
off to have lunch with them now I see
them all the time and they're dear old
friends you know so she has got that
wonderful coastery of of broads and
Dames who make her laugh and cackle and
she has a great sense of humor she
cannot laugh all the time and this is
clearly a woman who has who has
convictions and she's made this
transition to you know Queen consort the
interest that she had before are going
to be even more in the foreground I
would expect suspect yes and I think she
will still keep
which is an interesting
because she was coming of age women's
Liberation was really taking off I mean
Jermaine Greer when we were at the
barricades demanding equal pay but that
class of society I mean she left school
then they sent it to a finishing school
I want a terrible like you're done
you're finished now your one job is to
get married so you're like really just a
life support system to a to a womb
um so there were never any high
expectations for her but despite the
fact that she's now the queen consort so
she is kind of a human handbag in a way
draped over the arm of the king she is
an individual and she's got very strong
beliefs and passions which I I know she
will keep campaigning for women's rights
and she keeps campaigning against
domestic violence and also literacy
helping the underprivileged kids get
access to an education so I don't think
she's going to dip herself in
disinfectant in any way but in terms of
the relationship with Charles how would
you describe the relationship that the
two of them have well as he transitions
from you know the artist formerly known
as Prince you know to the king what is
he going to need more than anything a
right Royal laugh it is in his 70s it's
such a huge onerous burden to take that
on when most most people his age is
slipping on their carpet slippers and
doing a little bit of light gardening
and suddenly you know he's got this
massive job so to be able to have
someone who who can laugh at things she
does not suffer from an irony deficiency
um she's skeptical she's not easily LED
or manipulated but she's also full of
positivity and optimism she doesn't
think optimism is an eye disease which a
lot of you the Brits not you not not up
there in the north but famously you're a
Scotsman sitting here obviously you know
many English think that um you know
they've got a kind of Eeyore Gene she's
the opposite of that she's full of life
and laughter and love and when you see
them together
um first of all this is a love story
that has passed the test of time
whatever anyone you can't you can't say
that these are not two people who are
passionate about each other you know
she's found her knight in shining Armani
there he is and in in Camilla he's found
a True Companion
when you have such a privileged
aristocratic background how can you
relate to people whose lives are
completely different from you when she
was the Public Enemy Number One and she
understood what it was like to be cast
off into social Siberia
and and that's when you learn to value
your friends you learn to to to draw
deeply on your own resilience
and it gives you backbone doesn't it I
mean it does it gives you that kind of
fortitude so I'm I mean that must have
been absolutely life-changing for her to
suddenly find herself in that furnace
of Fury of public Fury and and to stay
the distance has been extraordinary even
though they are obviously very
privileged they are like a normal couple
you know they argue about the fact she's
always complaining that he likes to
throw open the bedroom window at higher
Grove and the gale force winds coming
through and like all women she likes to
be cozy and warm and who gets control of
the remote oh that's always the test
isn't it that's very good
you find out
look she's so warm and and real I
remember one day saying to her she
looked I said I look fantastic you know
it's a great outfit she just went over
to me and whispered Spanx I thought
I'd have the future Queen of England
telling me about her
husbands
I think people will be interested in all
these insights into Camilla but also I I
need to kind of ask about Charles
because at times you all had an insight
into the personality that none of us
have ever come close to yeah and at
times he he has appeared to be slightly
aloof perhaps slightly standoffish I
mean what is your impression of the man
well God
stiff up everything at all times the
royal family are the linchpin of the
class system because you meet people in
England all the time and say oh so and
so 33rd in line for the throne or 78. I
don't I don't meet people very often the
circles in which we move are different
but I take your point I do take your
point
I was at a party the other day and I
suddenly realized everyone at that party
had a castle you know except for me I
had a bouncy castle that was about it
that's not too bad it's not too bad it's
not too bad
when the queen died and Charles was
doing those walkabouts I mean the public
changed their opinion of him I think I
saw it and they were they were reaching
out to touch him in a way that obviously
had never happened with the queen as
well this was the softening of His Image
but with people who know him we that
that is the child that we know I mean
he's he's actually very self-deprecating
he's funny he's very funny his letters
are hilarious when I first met him which
was probably 30 years ago it was at an
event at Australia house and when he
came came you know his interview he came
by and and was in we were introduced and
I said to him well you know in Australia
we have inverted snobbery if you can
trace yourself back to the first or
second Fleet of criminals that makes you
Australian royalty and first and second
Fleet I am the creme de La Creme so I
said from one Monarch to another you
know g'day and once again his his
flunkies were like can't you really talk
to him that way and he just he just
bursts out laughing and then he asked me
what my ancestors being had been guilty
of and I said not running fast enough
and then he patted himself down to make
sure I hadn't stolen his wallet and then
he was kind of LED on to a more a less
Mischief as guess but I could see he
really enjoyed not being treated like a
porcelain Prince he is different from
the upper class even though he's the
Pinnacle of the upper class in a way but
you know most English people you have to
do open heart surgery to know what's
going on inside them right facial
Expressions by Taxidermy you know their
voices are so brittle it's like they've
got
osteoporosis and vocal osteoporosis but
he's not like that he has always been so
open about his passions about the
environment and his passionate love of
Camilla Etc so he's not a typical
Englishman in my view he's he's he's
different and I think the public will
absolutely come to see that side of him
and and love it
I don't want it to pry too much but in
fact I do want to apply too much to to
what extent does does does Diana still
cast a shadow over over their
relationship do you think oh
oh gosh I I couldn't really say that's
just such a personal question the
emotional roller coaster they're they're
on on a regular basis because it's
brought up time and time again now
they're doing the crown Etc so you know
I thought it was interesting in the
crown though how the public attitude has
changed in so many ways because at the
time remember
um Camilla gate remember the recordings
when he Charles said he wanted to be her
tampon and everyone was so horrified by
that I wasn't at the time I thought how
great have a man has not gynophobic
fabulous
I think people have generally warmed to
their relationship because it's so
authentic and you know he obviously
adores her he's always saying my darling
wife my dear wife I mean it's so sincere
and also he's a man of passion I know
we're talking about the fact he was
raised in this very stiff
um environment but he's always had
passions I mean he's been so passionate
about the environment and we all made
jokes about that in the beginning he was
so ahead of his time and I mean I used
to make jokes about you know Prince
Charles hugging his shoe trees I mean we
all did and looking back he was so right
and he was ridiculed constantly but he
always held firm to his passionate views
on the environment and now of course
we've caught up and it'll be interesting
to see if he resonates with young people
because of course especially in
Australia I mean Australia's the most
Multicultural nation in the world and
we're like a human minestrone and you
know why do all that you would our new
immigrants have bear any allegiance to a
a monarch 12 000 miles away in a in a
castle encrusted environment but he does
reach across the generation divide
through his environmental concerns so
it'll be really interesting to see if he
Chimes within the next generation I
don't know how important was it to both
of them that Camilla would be would be
Queen I mean that was obviously
something that was in the gift of Queen
Elizabeth herself and she made a she
made a real point of that announcement
which frankly when I heard it kind of I
think it took us all pretty much my
surprise perhaps not those who were in
the Inner Circle oh and I wasn't
surprised at all I mean anyone can see
that it's a love match but particularly
if you're in their family and also to
legitimize this this long tortuous
romance they've had to actually give it
the stamp of of approval and yeah it had
to be and she'll be fabulous
isn't that one of the important things
for the roles moving forward that if
they are not more of the 21st century
then they have been in the past you know
then the the time time might be up well
modernizing the royal family is a is
oxymoronic because it's a feudal system
isn't it you know like Surfs Up
the only way to stay vaguely relevant is
to is to become more accessible and
become more slim down become um you know
more useful which are all the things
that Charles is doing so you know we'll
see do you think that the mod royal
family will be here in this form 100
years from now as a republican yourself
do you see significant longevity to this
royal family
not in the Commonwealth Britain becomes
less and less relevant to that to the
rest of the world so I think that will
definitely that will fade and Shrink I
mean if you talk to most Australians
about
the queen they thought you were talking
about Elton John so you know and the
same with talking about the king I mean
I think you're talking about Elvis
Presley so for overseas no but for in
Britain I don't know this is a country
that hemorrhages history there's a host
of ghosts in every nook and cranny so
even just for nostalgic reasons you know
like a museum piece you might keep this
this show rolling but then again perhaps
it'll become like a theme park where you
can you can pay to go and and the the
king for the day and sit on the throne I
mean I don't know we shall see Kathy
it's been lovely John T thanks very much
my thanks to Kathy and of course to you
for listening to this guy News Daily
with me Neil Patterson this Edition was
produced by Annie Joyce our editor is
Philly Bowman
and just a quick reminder if you're
interested in watching my documentary
it's called my king my country and you
can find it on our on-demand services
including YouTube Sky q and catch up